you guys made a big announcement at
Comic Con what is it yeah well I was
asked did I get everything I wanted for
my birthday which was yesterday happy
birthday the truth was no and I asked if
they could just I wanted everyone to see
the show and I thought what a perfect
birthday present from Hulu and I just
said can we release them today
and they said yes whoooaa he's called
you like early you called me and you
said drop it I said do I have a pole to
do this and it was a public forum so
they just said yes so now it's out and
people can see it a week early what took
y'all so long I mean come on I don't
know well I think I mean to be honest
it's I think what's what's cooler than
what took us so long is that somehow our
fans are just factually the coolest fans
in the world and never gave up and
they're the reason that we're sitting
here marshmallows baby baby let's say
the market oh wow so the marshmallows
get what they want but more importantly
each your birthday was yesterday yeah
yeah how was your birthday and there you
put up the best video of your kids
because it's crazy kids don't understand
how old their parents are they they're
107 what were you shocked at all by your
kids calling you 6:00 in their 60s and
80s do you think mommy's turning she
said 63 and then I said to the older one
who should be smarter smarter than the
little one I said how old do you think I
am Lincoln she said 89 and then I said
to my husband how old do you think I'm
turning and I said he said I think they
are about right maybe somewhere in the
middle
like maybe they were speaking like your
spiritual age old woman spirit yeah
hello everyone I was like I'm turning 39
tomorrow so tomorrow you want to ask me
anything I'm obviously a very sage know
everything by 39 so let me know but no
it's a great birthday how is it being
here and what is the reaction like cause
you just did a panel what was that like
this is a third time I think they've
been here for this is the biggest and
best so far bigger and better every time
and some of us are from San Diego yeah
it felt nice because you you're coming
to a very like a hungry scenario
everybody's really excited they know
that that Rob our Creator has evolved
the show to be a much more adult world
so there's definitely something new you
don't have to have watched the original
series to be a part of it but to come
and have this much hunger rather than
just being like a new show and being
like look at us we also have a new show
here it was great that the fans were
like ready and waiting I know they've
been waiting for a long leave you me
I mean how many times we asked you about
Veronica Mars infinite enjoy well that's
one of the arguing points I had when I
wanted to like make it again and when
Rob and I went around and pitched it I
was like I can't tell you every single
interview I do about anything else about
the good place about frozen but hustle
eyes any other job I've had they always
bring it back to Veronica Mars what was
the moment when you guys got on set and
you're like whoa it feels like we never
forgot how to play the song was there a
moment like that going back into the
office Mars investigators gonna say that
the office was identical okay
premier was saying haroset once you see
you know you see I'm gonna you see him
at the trailers and you see
around you give your big hugs Rico gives
the best hugs when you see him so he
just full embrace but when I got back on
set and Wallace was standing in front of
me she looks like different though an 89
[Laughter]
was there a moment for you when you got
out there they came on set with us and
standing high heels for 16 hours at our
Hardy scene and they were the most
enthusiastic background you've ever seen
and we partied with these guys that it
was really like sharing a family
speaking is like the new person to join
this is gross it really is like a family
I've described it before is like going
home to Isaac because I obviously Cavey
and I did the good place together and
housewife I described it as like going
home to meet your boyfriend's family
like you know your boyfriend by the way
just below this studio is the good place
cafe did you know that really yeah you
have to go maybe they'll let you jump in
line there's a lot come on you know what
we also have a little surprise for you
guys
Nile is here and she's here with
make-a-wish and she wanted to talk
so excited but you an artist do you
dress them wonderful I love your work
I'm frozen good place everything for a
song ask you what inspired you to become
an actress what movies and a specific
actor actress anybody it for me it was
actually music because I started singing
when I was like 11 or 12 years old and
and just sort of trained up radically
and then was given musical theater songs
to sing and I was like wait I can tell a
story while I sing it's not just pretty
notes in my head it's like I can tell a
story and stories are so engaging and I
was like maybe I want to do it without
music I did like like after school
classes at this drama class it was more
like a community center and it was just
really fun similarly we did like it was
like I was a child and we just did songs
and dance and little improvisations and
it was just I think it was just being
like oh I can I can have fun and then
realizing that you can make a living
from that as well my inspiration was my
family just trying to get our family to
laugh who's the play a game called make
me laugh you said stand in the middle of
the circle and the first person to laugh
has to sweet spot to stand in that
circle and that's where you might want
to try that with my family now mine was
Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure I saw
that I don't do that whatever I did
Gilligan's Island for me I just couldn't
get enough
they looked like they were having the
best time in the world and I had no fun
as a child I could get out of school you
do things you liked doing with them like
ice for fun because I know you dress up
as Anna from frozen one time well my
daughter likes to draw so much which is
why I asked if you were an artist cause
she she draws when she's happy she draws
when she's sad if we get into an
argument she's six years old she will
sit down and draw a terrible version
looks like bubbles saying no no angry
mama it's like one of her outlets so we
do a lot of art how she processes
everybody I think most people you have
kids permanently we have like I got
three three yeah I got to I got to all
right guys we're really gonna do he
likes to make a comic book every day or
create a game every day so we'll play
games cut the TV I'll take the
electronics away and just play games I
need to find interesting ways to get my
kids out of their room kids are 22 at
night I have no idea that's a man
that is awesome thank you for coming
here and how cool is it to meet these
guys amazing it's a pleasure beating my
mom's a big fan of your work and I just
wanted to say that she says hi to you
and she wishes to come here and by the
way there's a lot of great stories when
you bring this family back all right
thanks